on n'arrête pas le progrès ça fait
beaucoup rire c'est parce que je
l'entendais dire que ce qui s'écrit ici
voilà on est fan mais écoutez je suis
utile à sion si on peut le revoir ou pas
la leur chien c'est un chant magnifique
formidable on va demander à notre
dernière invités de cette édition
pauline de breteuil bonsoir si vous
appréciez ce petit chien qui rigole
parce qu'ils allaient saisir une blague
en pour vous sortir à chaque sens facile
on verra d'accord je voulais au défi à
chaque fois qu'on sera renouvelable de
mettre le petit chien qui va bien au bon
moment en tout cas on va parler on va
parler toujours de noël dans cette
édition spéciale du 7-8 avec est notre
nouvel invité pauline de breteuil et le
château de breteuil aux couleurs de noël
jusqu'au 15 janvier juste avant si on a
les vannes aux saint-quentinois préféré
pour demander quelle décoration pour
noël comment vous avez décorer vos
appartements et voit sa fin vous
écoutent les choses ça c'est classique
finalement donc dire plein de bouts de
neige les petites d'épisodes chez en
bois des jeux comme ça un petit sapin
oui puis la porte la porte d'entrée fait
la décoration du sapin est
essentiellement sur les sur les vitres
donc on met le père noël les flocons
neige de préférence on essaie de prendre
avec les effigies du moment des enfants
en ce moment ce serait plutôt flash
mcqueen
voilà avec avec le
le bonnet du père noël et voilà et si
vous manquez toujours d'idées pourquoi
ne pas vous inspiré du travail réalisé
au château de breteuil le château qui la
nuit tombée s'illumine vous allez le
voir en images avec une photographie
pauline de breteuil donc à l'occasion
des fêtes vous avait redécoré ce château
à quoi il ressemble actuellement et on
n'oublie pas d'afficher la photo dès
qu'elle sera prête à la voix la superbe
on a ici créer de crier quelque chose
d'un peu féerique
désolé j'ai la voix à la méchante
sorcière mais rejeté très féerique avec
dans les étages un décor assez nobles
comme on aurait pu avoir un noël aux 19e
et dans les cuisines on s'est lâché on a
fait quelque chose de kiki qui est un
décor qu'on pourrait aimer à la maison
mais en sublimer givré et blanc nous
avons eu deux filles dans une autre qui
dans une cuisine évidemment plein de
gourmandise il ya des petits enfants qui
qui résistent pas alors on rajouter pour
man 10 au fur et à mesure des jeux pour
les enfants c'est très sympa et un décor
qui se mange
vous avez décorer la table spécialement
quand vous faites à chaque saison chaque
saison chaque saison en fait on a
plusieurs pièces du château qui sont
décorées ainsi que les extérieurs mais
les intérieurs sont très prisés parce
que les gens froide ou qui visitent
beaucoup le château est en fait ils
aiment que tout au long de la visite qu
on leur rappelle noël deux manières soit
discrète soit dans les cuisines ou dans
la salle à manger ce qui s'y prête bien
de manière très féerique justement
chacun mais il faut se réinventer aussi
où les bébés constante tout de même dans
la création
non on essaye chaque année de vraiment
d'installer la nouveauté parce qu'on a
vraiment un public qui nous suit qui
nous aiment
des fidèles et ce qu'on veut c'est à
chaque fois qu'ils se disent web
on voit quelques images
d autres éditions nous étions venus vous
voir sur les autres voies mais la
dernière très joli tacle d'ailleurs fait
par lily c'est ça exactement savions
alors ce château vous vous l'avez
toujours connu comme ça qu'elle quels
souvenirs vous avez du château de
breteuil à noël à noël et c'est un
moment un peu magique parce que c'est
les vacances
il ya beaucoup de gens qui restent
justement dans les divines et donc en
fait il ya beaucoup d'enfants la vraie
midi donc on aime beaucoup à avorter
dire ceci très très très bien avec les
contes de perrault
donc moi j'en ai une image soit sous la
neige
parce que il ya parfois la neige aux
états unis on n'en a peut-être pas mais
avec toujours cette idée de fada bon feu
de quelque chose d'aussi de d'un team
on essaie de créer en fait dans
certaines pièces aussi du château
notamment on a ça monte donc après avoir
visité en avoir plein les yeux
bah on peut en fait justement se régaler
de crêpes devant un bon feu on essaie de
recréer une quelques jours un petit peu
plus familial chaleureux
est ce que c'est vous qui faites les
crêpes est non c'est pas une abeille
soeur argent m'a fait parler justement
c'est une affaire des familles dont on
s'y met tous j'ai juste avoir une petite
parenthèse parce que vous avez mentionné
ces fameux conte de perrault on le sait
le château de breteuil c'est le lieu
avait hésité pour les redécouvrir et en
animation mais j'ai retrouvé une
interview de vous qui étape de 2008 et
vous disiez que à la question est ce que
quelque chose vous tapez sur les nerfs
vous aviez répondu oui la belle au bois
dormant
vous tapez sur les nerfs la belle au
bois dormant vous disiez je sais c'est
méchant mais le symbole de la fille
passive qui attend le prince
je trouve ça de destructeur dans
l'éducation des petites filles
oui ça dure ça je signe celle qui est
monde seront seront très symbolique et
c'est vrai que pour moi
je dis en tant que féministe caen 1-2
traditionnel j'ai toujours trouvé se
condamne à un feu gilles ans voilà c'est
dit et vous le signe et vous la verrez
assumer quatre ans plus tard donc noël
abreu tc du 9 décembre au 15 janvier
2013 et d'autres sites dans le
département se sont parés de leurs
habits de noël c'est le cas de la
bergerie de rambouillet la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet qui accueille
une crèche vivante
les animaux de la ferme sont mises en
scène un sujet de valérie auribeau et
patrick jacques de dixmude à les mamans
enfin fondement
enzo et sa maman sont venus profiter des
activités organisées pour les fêtes par
la bergerie nationale de rambouillet ici
ce sont les ateliers créatifs du père
noël
des ateliers du père noël où ils peuvent
créer quelque chose pour par rapport à
noël plein de choses à mettre dans le
sapin donc on a des guirlandes on a des
cartes des cartes de voeux à faire des
petites des petits anges avec des
paillettes et tout ça il peut faire
celle ci ils choisissent toutes les
activités qu'ils veulent faire la crèche
vivante l activité phare qui séduit le
plus les animaux de la ferme y attendent
les petites mains dans une lumière
tamisée et au pied du sapin
il avait la garde de notre petit suisse
on voulait faire la surprise de venir
voir les animaux c'est ici que les
enfants peuvent écrire leur lettre au
père noël
là aussi des indices découverts au fur
et à mesure de la visite permet d'avoir
une petite récompense une dégustation à
l'auberge du père noël jus de pomme pain
d'épicés fruits secs et chocolat pour
réchauffer les petits gourmands
voici la clé pour trouver tous les
indices et y en avait un dans la crèche
un autre dans la basse cour et pour les
autres il faudra chercher ces activités
sont proposées jusqu'à noël date de la
fermeture de la bergerie nationale pour
les vacances d'hiver pour l'hymne de
bretonne une très jeune et vendre à
bretelles et c'est une excellente idée
pourquoi plusieurs crèches qui viendront
du monde entier mais une crèche vivante
je retiens une idée pourquoi pas vous
inspirer de faire du côté de la bergerie
de rambouillet beaucoup de sites
toujours forcément à visiter dans le
département surtout en cette période de
fin d'année on va parler de ce que vous
proposez tout de même encore à breteuil
et ses fameux compte encore plus à
l'honneur durant cette période de fin
d'année pendant les vacances scolaires à
16h30 un conte de noël tous les jours et
je vous ai dit que on avait beaucoup
d'enfants et la cançon qu'on se doit de
bien les recevoir et que ça reste
quelque chose vraiment l'expérience
fihri pour eux donc en fait notre
conteuse elle est là évidemment 4h30
mais elle devient elle devient costumés
en mère noël à deux périodes dans la
semaine la reine des neiges
exactement et puis on a également donc
un atelier couture pas simplement pour
les petites filles on peut faire des
tutus mais on peut faire aussi une cape
de chat botté à sandra donc malgré tout
les goûts les garçons et les filles
exactement les mersen est oublié c'est
un dispositif important lourd que vous
mettez en place on va pas rentrer dans
le détail du coût mais c'est
véritablement important financièrement
c'est aussi nécessaire j'imagine pour
continuer à faire venir le public de
revenir sur tout en fait on sent que
s'ils voulaient qu'une visite anonyme
juste avec des audioguides ça ne
fonctionne pas dans le cadre auteuil
on a besoin de vraiment d'incarner
l'histoire d'un côté et où les contes de
perrault de l'autre les enfants vraiment
on sent qui s'anime quand justement ils
sont en face de quelqu'un qui killer qui
leur met en scène en fait des histoires
et ça change un peu tout dans notre
manière de faire les choses et d'être
perçue aussi par le public c'est très
important cette incarnation même
personne vous attendez pas sur cette
période de fin d'année aux six mois que
dans les grosses périodes d'été mais je
pense qu'on pouvait dans les dix mille
dix mille personnes attendues du côté du
château de breteuil et peut-être vous
c'est bientôt la fin de cette édition
spéciale du cette suite vous savez ce
que vous allez offrir à noël ça y est
j'ai eu tous les jours un mail à
j'essayais en tout cas nous sommes allés
poser la question on repart une dernière
fois dans les rues de saint quentin en
yvelines qu'allez vous offrir à noël
vos réponses alors à ma femme je vais je
vais faire comme monsieur ibrahimovic je
vais je suis là c'est son seul cadeau
qu'elle rastan et un sac à main pour
madame il mon frère un sac maman un
spectacle et mon papa
du chocolat a gps ça mon mari smartbox
j'suis pas je sais pas donc smartbox et
je m'embête pas beaucoup de jouer à mes
enfants surtout papa ma fille eva voire
d'un ordinateur pour se caler au collège
moi je vais avoir un appareil photo
enfin tout ce qu'ils voient
l'informatique numérique et vous
monsieur le père noël qu'est ce que vous
aimeriez avoir comme cadeau à noël
beaucoup de sourires des enfants et des
baisers des petits hors de tous ses
enfants et que les enfants soient
heureux et je vous le disais cette
édition est presque fini on va demander
à antony valeri de revenir vous êtes
parfait en servera n'oubliez pas qu'on
n'ait pas mis trop rapprochées ou du
micro pas très bien et valérie je sais
c'est formidable merci beaucoup à la fin
c'est là dessus que s'achève savent
écouter j'ai déjà servi merci anthony
mais en tout cas je vois qu'en régie y
sont passés par là j'imagine que dans
les coulisses ils se sont servis la cie
poli je me retiens vous en prie pour le
macaron c'était un plaisir pour nous
alors merci frank lobos l'un de nos
invités ce soir cette édition 7,8 retard
mais oui merci à nos invités de ce soir
au cinéma les yeux d'elsa l'office de
tourisme de saint quentin en yvelines le
secours populaire français le
chocolatier fente de brusque que vous
avez remercié wilfried et pauline de
breteuil bien sûr merci c'est la
rédaction tv fini sur l'action merci
johanna merci aux équipes techniques
réalisation signée romain respini on
vous retrouve très prochainement est sur
notre antenne et du lundi au jeudi à 18h
pour le 7-8 plus classique le point sur
l'information locale
joyeux noël forcément en vous retrouvant
janvier et puis merci aussi aux
stagiaires comparaison avec ont aperçu
dans les mains
il